picture this
your evil geniuses and you're playing in
the grand finals of the Rainbow six
siege Pro League finals in Milan you're
up a map and you steamrolled your way to
championship point and it'll be the
yokai drone and Nathan Valenti who push
eg to match points there's only one
round left the clock is counting it down
you're up three players to two all you
have to do is hold out for 30 seconds
you'll be world champions here comes the
tension here comes the push but the
crazy thing is even with all the odds in
your favor no one expects you to win why
because you've been here before you've
already come within an inch of glory and
watched as a win that should have been
yours slip through your fingers
Giavanna just waiting now look to push
together the defuser in a position where
they'll have to see when the hip on it
goes through one will cover the doorway
as they start to diffuse and you go
through one on the young
until today and now it's about to happen
again the lead it doesn't matter the
odds are irrelevant little do you know
against every expectation you're about
to choke even harder than before here
comes the tension here comes the push
waiting for the vault on in is Canadian
will he be able to secure the kill he
sees the tracers don't know the nerves
it's the nerves alright but before we
get into all that I want to make sure to
tell you guys to tune in to be softs
Rainbow six siege US Nationals the
finals are coming up on the 13th and
trust me you do not want to miss it for
more on that and all kinds of six siege
action check out the links in the
description below now in order to
understand just how bad Iggy's choke was
you have to understand the stakes behind
it you need to understand everything
this roster had been through up to that
point they're good guys once upon a time
eg were juggernauts and in eSports
dominated by Europeans this Canadian led
crew was a diamond in the rough
back then they played it as continuum
and they proved that North America had
what it took to be the best it's 1 V 2 4
LM this is going to be the deciding
factor continuum can't find him but
that's the second enough time to diffuse
continuum of the first North American
team to win rainbow 6 protein in
addition to being the only North
American roster to ever win a Pro League
final they also entered the first six
Invitational in 2017 as favorites
thanks to Canadiens unparalleled ability
to counter stretch we're a fast paced
team that relies heavily on counter
strats as well as having some of the
most talented players in the world
and with the entirety of North America
behind them continuum one cementing
themselves as the best sees roster in
the world they equal pushes weigh-in
is it tucked in the corner 10 seconds to
go comes on around loses the fight the
Canadian once ago it's a V to learn and
drop down particular your world
champions
the problem is that after hoisting the
hammer and Montreal continuum fell into
a bit of a slump continue of your world
champions are done in this season
they're Purdy and elevate to advance to
playoffs
did that just sneak up on anyone else is
it am I the only one feeling the like
the bafflement that CTM just kind of
limited from the pro league but not
making it to finals one reason for this
was that Europe decided to put their
foot down and remind North America who
was in charge this led to a slew of
incredible new teams including Penta a
super team led by rising star penguin
I'm a very dedicated player and I've
accumulated over 8,000 hours of actual
play time in the game which is almost a
year by the 2018 Invitational Canadian
and his teammates were yesterday's news
despite being the defending champions no
one was thinking about eg all eyes were
on Penta but eg were resilient they
topped their group grinded their way to
the grand finals and found themselves
with a two map lead over the team that
overshadowed them all year and they are
down Oh [ __ ] two and then in the third
map it all came crashing down Penta is
absolutely crushing eg now Canadian once
again in a situation where he will need
to clutch so one before take him down to
Mexico health he'll take Koga but he now
has a shield in his way very difficult
with only one bill to eliminate amante
but Penta takes their first map slowly
but surely
eg crumbled it wasn't just that they
couldn't close they couldn't do anything
they couldn't shoot they couldn't
strategize it's like they forgot how to
place each possibly goes for a plant
baiting it out goes through the 80s
their Crocs can't hit it dot at fabien
wins it
is that half it before eg nuit Penta one
two maps and we're on the verge of
closing out the biggest comeback siege
had ever seen it's 2-2 its Penghu and
Fabi left two of the best no employers
on that look at that sufficient prior
Bobby and down its Penghu the ash just
waited or rather the apana just waited
now look to push together the diffuser
in a position where they'll have to see
when the hip on it goes through one hole
cover the doorway as they start abusing
the most wins now of any team including
a whole world championship evil geniuses
just let it slip by an inch in the
months after Iggy's cataclysmic choke
most people in the community we're
wondering the same thing
how could you possibly bounce back from
a loss that traumatizing I know I the
invitation on when I was talking to a
Amara when you when you guys lost and
then you and you took some time before
you came out to see me and he went back
and got yet to make sure you were okay
they're good guys
[Music]
the crazy thing is EJ did bounce back a
few months later at the Paris major eg
grinded all the way back to the grand
finals to face off against Penghu and
his compatriots yet again the problem is
that this time they fell right out of
the gate they lost two maps almost
immediately and then slowly lost grip on
the third
[Music]
he failed to find the opener not a
single map and by the 2019 Invitational
they couldn't even make it past the
quarterfinals where he won against
laxing relaxing on a charm city
eliminate evil geniuses
this day would come
and the quarters like this in a big
state by the time the pro league season
9 finals rolled around it felt like eg
his time had come and gone like that one
horrific collapse against Penta had
broken their spirits beyond repair and
that they'd never reach another Grand
Finals again I don't own win one the
thing is that's what everyone said the
last time and just like last time
eg weren't ready to bow out on top of a
roster change they made several role
swaps injecting new life into a cast of
seasoned veterans who had been together
forever and as soon as the tournament
started its showed they both make it in
on the vault geo should still have an
echo Truong remaining and there goes
cyber nabis on the trade on two canadian
behind the deployable command with the
diffusers down there's one second left
now visitor one v3 Evil Geniuses to the
semi-final T it's phase North America
has a representative on championship
Sunday in season nine the problem was
Iggy's grand finals opponent team empire
a lean mean Russian killing machine who
had their names on the trophy since day
one a Herculean effort is required but
magnet gets down finished off aces will
need to be able to do anything but it's
a perfect third
Empire cannot be stopped and that
machine that we talked about will not
break now it will not break ever
needless to say the community was
skeptical that eg could win this final
Empire were a ridiculously explosive
roster often considered the best in the
world people were expecting a beatdown
this is gonna be a repeat of Sao Paolo
two years ago or this is the underdog
story but they weren't expecting eg to
deliver it right now eg is just
demolishing empire on this route Gino
gets that how about a flawless round how
about a start as good as you're gonna
find for the eg round after round
eg pummeled Empire into the dirt they
were counted stratum their way to what
was looking like North America's first
World Championship in over two years and
it seems like Empire can't recover at
this point they're at the double window
waiting and prepped and ready with geo
low on HP and it was right at that
moment match point
mere seconds from vindication that
everything went to [ __ ] which brings us
back here here comes the tension here
comes the push Canadian didn't need to
peek white stairs but he did and here's
what happened next down on white stairs
waiting for the vault on in is Canadian
will he be able to secure the kill he
sees the tracers don't know Scyther will
win the fight he'll inch his way on up
Gio is gonna be next in line but this
could be a tough shot an empire could
wrestle away the round
there's Gio just waiting he doesn't pull
the trigger he sees he pops up oh no Gio
you gotta hate your shots young will be
the last one left he was so important
for faze he turns his back he's got the
pistol but shepard will deny the come
back from ichi on that round
the thing is EG had plenty of chances to
right the ship but they didn't have one
round field their fate but some na fans
held out hope after all there was no way
EG could choke even harder than last
time
right bunch of free kills here for
whoever that is it's geo pops up for
behind and gets no it doesn't shut down
by choice to pick the way and that crux
will be sent through their Shepard as
well and it's falling apart at the seams
for evil geniuses evil geniuses have
just not been present
eg sitting now on the precipice of
defeat this could be the end of each
cheese miracle return to form and then
be cable watches Gio goes for the plan
to sound cute we'll give Tim the
information all he takes what down
higher will rise as you crown a new
champion here Yugi should have won that
serious but even though they didn't they
still walked away from it feeling
empowered like they finally were
remembered what it was like to play at
their level no one was negative about it
like ever everyone right after like like
that sucked that stung like everyone had
that reaction no it's not going to but
like by the time we took like took a
little time off and we talked about it
after like everyone felt good everyone
was like like we played it insane
unfortunately after falling short at the
Raleigh major canadian and his teammates
decided that an amicable split was an
order canadian went on to join
spacestation gaming well EG replaced him
with an up-and-comer it was the end of
one of CJ's greatest eras Canadian and
his teammates are without a doubt one of
the greatest rosters to ever touch seeds
they're the only North American roster
to ever win a Pro League final or an
invitational and milan reminded us why
no one expected them to make it that far
and the result was one of the most
memorable scenes finals of all time so
here's to the EGS of the world
the ones who fell short the ones who
should have won but didn't they had to
game in the palm of their hand man they
threw in the trash because without them
eSports would be a hell of a lot less
interesting
what a wonderful match an absolute
heartbreaker they got that feeling
Michael at least I did that we were
looking at an opportunity to go to
overtime it sure did feel like we were
back at a 6 e thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages